listen Drew I want you to have a
conversation with one of these gentlemen
outside of this show because I am firmly
convinced you will fall in love and have
one of the greatest experiences of your
life
but now it's up to you number one two
three or or four three two one four
three one four two go ahead
I wish for every woman out there to know
that you can write your own story and
that if anyone was in my seat right now
I do want to throw up like I this is the
most don't be self-conscious your
surreal experience
um guys are you going to take offense if
you lose are you going to be okay if you
don't get Drew's uh number absolutely
it'll be difficult for a minute but I'm
okay with
it'll be sad fair enough fair enough I
would I mean is an option to pick all
four of you and see what happens after
this no no gotta pick one absolutely
come on I'm forced to choose one Drew
you're not buying a condo you're just
choosing a husband come on I don't ever
wanna get married ever I understand but
you'll get but when you see all these
guys are you will marry them it's okay I
see them no no no no no that's not Chuck
Barris set it up this way
oh glad her see us all four of these
guys are quality guys I'm honored to
have them on myself I believe that's why
I I'm like a partner you must make the
decision or not no you've got to make it
I've never I never saw Chuck Barris
wrestle with the contestant I will go
against my own gut which was to say you
all know where to find me afterwards no
no no no no no Dan used to say men build
Bridges they want to get from one place
to the other and there's no way to get
there they build a [ __ ] Bridge follow
your heart through women and men out
there it's true about the ghosts don't
take it personally true you're
stonewalling I wanna hear one two three
or four and Howard I'm gonna make a
choice because you're not gonna let me
get away with it right I will pick
number two
number two
[Applause]